this is 1401
i'm john gruber and uh this is uh
microeconomics
um today i want to i want to cover three
things i want to talk about the course
details
uh i want about what is microeconomics
and then i'll talk start our
start uh the substance of the course by
talking about supply and demand
a couple of points about the course the
course will have a distinct sort of
policy
angle to it i sort of do economic policy
is government policy is my thing
so i i think it's what makes economics
exciting and it sort of offers
i think an interesting angle to
understand why we're learning what we're
learning i think sometimes in an intro
class it's sort of hard to understand
why the heck you're doing things um
however that's just sort of a slight
flavor if you're really more interested
in this i teach a whole course called
1441. i'm not teaching it this year
but it'll be taught by a visitor in the
spring uh kristen butcher from wellesley
and i'll be teaching it next year
that dies much more into these policy
issues so i'm going to sort of use
government policy sort of an organizing
theme but it won't be sort of the
dominant theme of the class
finally three points about my teaching
style um i don't write everything in the
board we're not in high school anymore
you're actually responsible for what i
say not what i write uh
partly that's because my handwriting is
brutal um as you can tell already
um uh so what that means is please
please do not be afraid to ask me what
the hell i just wrote on the board
okay there's no shame in that don't just
lean to your neighbor and say what the
hell is writing the board like
ask me because if you can't read it i'm
sure someone else can't read it so feel
free to ask
and in general please feel free to
engage with questions in this class
the other point of my teaching style is
i talk way too fast
and the longer i go there's a
mathematical function which is the
longer i go without interruption the
faster i speak
until i just spin off okay so basically
please ask questions if anything's not
clear or you just want to
ask questions about some related tangent
or whatever please feel free to do so
you might think how would that work in a
class this big there's always way too
few questions
even a class is big so never be afraid
that like it'll slow me down or whatever
i ask a question we have plenty of time
on the class
and you'll be doing your classmates a
favor because it'll slow me down
um finally last point i have this
terrible tendency to use the term
guys in a gender-neutral way so this
class i like to see looks like it's a
fairly healthy representation both males
and females when i say guys i don't mean
men i mean people
i mean people so don't take it women
don't take it personally
guys means economic agents it means
people it doesn't mean men it's just the
way just a bad tendency drives my life
crazy but
i've decided better to just apologize up
front than try to
try to fix it throughout which is
impossible okay
so let's talk about what is
microeconomics okay
so fundamentally microeconomics
how people took ap high school econ
okay um how many people
for how many for how many was it taught
really well
okay that's about that right that's why
i did my high school online class that's
the answer i wanted to hear
um uh okay so uh tell your friends still
in high school
we're taking its lecon if your high
school econ teacher isn't great tell
them to go on edx and take the class
uh and and help out your friends still
in high school
okay so um what is microeconomics
microeconomics is the study of how
individuals and firms
make decisions in a world of scarcity
scarcity is what drives microeconomics
okay
basically what microeconomics is is a
series
of constrained optimization exercises
where economic agents be they firms or
individuals
try to make themselves as well off as
possible
given their constraints yeah
i will but not as much as i should uh
essentially we have another course in
the department called 1413
behavioral economics which gets in that
much more i will sprinkle it throughout
but uh
but not as much as i actually believe in
it uh in other words the
way we think about economics is it's
best to sort of get the basics down
before you start worrying about the
deviations
find better to climb the tree before you
start going out in the branches
um okay so basically um
what this course is then about is it's
about trade-offs
it's about how do you given that you're
constrained how do you trade off things
to make yourself as well off as possible
and behind this notion of trade-offs is
going to be
i'll say about a hundred times this is
the most important thing in the course
so just ignore that
but this is one of the most important
things i'll say one of the most
important things in the course
is the notion of opportunity cost
opportunity cost is a very important
concept
that uh we teach sort of the first
concept we teach
um which is that every action
or every inaction has a cost
and that you could have been doing
something else instead okay
so if you buy a shirt you could have
bought pants
if you sit at home and watch tv you
could have been out working
everything you do has the next best
alternative you could have done instead
and that is called the opportunity cost
okay
and that's a critical concept in
economics
and that is why in some sense we are
called referred to casually as the
dismal science
economics referred to as the dismal
science first of all i'm flattered we're
considered a science
uh or called the dismal science because
our whole point is that
nothing is free there's always a
trade-off there's always an opportunity
cost
anything you do you could be doing
something else instead
okay and your constrained optimization
means you're gonna have to pass up one
thing
uh to do another now some may call it
dismal
but as a former mit undergraduate i call
it fun and this is why i think mit
is the perfect place to be teaching
economics because mit
engineering is all about constrained
optimization that's what engineering is
and economics is just the engine it's
just the principles you learn
you learn engineering um uh applied in
different contexts
so there's if we think about the 2007
contest that still exists with the
robots
2007. yeah okay the 2007 contest those
you know is a contest where you're given
a limited set of materials
and you have to build a robot that does
some tasks like pushing ping-pong balls
off a table or something like that
okay that's just constrained
optimization it's got nothing to do with
economics
but it's constrained optimization so
just think of
um just think of uh microeconomics
as like engineering but actually
interesting okay
so think of microeconomics as
engineering but instead of building
something to push a ping pong ball off
tables
you actually build people's lives and
businesses and
understand the decisions that drive our
economy okay
so the same principles that you could
think of for engineering classes but
applied to people's lives
and that's why in fact modern economics
was born in this room either this room
or 26-100
okay by paul samuelson in the 1940s and
50s
who wrote the fundamental textbook that
gave birth to modern economics
because he was here and applied the kind
of engineering principles
of mit to actually develop the field of
modern economics
what we learned today was developed at
mit so it's a great place to be learning
it
now with that as background okay any
questions about that
about what is microeconomics okay
with that as background let's turn to
our for the first
model we'll talk about this semester
which is the supply and demand model
supply and demand now the way we're
going to proceed in this course
is going to drive you crazy because
we're going to proceed
by teaching very s as the very first
question pointed out by teaching
very simplified models okay we're gonna
essentially
what is a model a model is technically a
description between any two or more
economic variables or any two or more
variables okay
but unlike the models used in all your
other classes
these aren't laws by and large they're
models so we don't have a relationship
between energy and mass which you can
write down to law and we're done
we have models which are never 100 true
but always pretty true pretty being
somewhere between
10 and 95 percent true okay so basically
the idea is to make a trade-off we want
to write down
in our models a set of simplifying
assumptions
that allow us with a relatively small
set of steps
to capture relatively broad phenomena
okay
so there's essentially a trade-off on
the one hand we'd like a model
that captures as well as possible the
phenomenon the real world
like equals nc squared but we want to do
so
in the most tractable possible way so
that we can teach it from first
principles and not
you know don't need don't need an hour
to teach every single uh
every single insight we have okay so
basically
in economics we tend to resolve that by
erroring on the side of
tractability that is why i can teach you
the entire field of microeconomics
which is really sort of macro is kind of
a fun application micro's really
economics
okay i could teach you the fire field of
microeconomics at a semester because
we're going to make a whole huge set
of simplifying assumptions to make
things tractable
but the key thing is that you will be
amazed at what these models will be able
to do
with a fairly simple set of models we'll
be able to offer insights and explain a
whole huge variety of phenomena
never perfectly but always pretty well
generally pretty well
okay and so that is essentially the
trade-off we're going to try to do
uh this semester so the line i like is
this the statistician george box
said that all models are wrong but some
are useful
now obviously it doesn't apply to models
models in the hard sciences but in the
social sciences that's true
and basically i'm going to write down a
set of models like that
now with every model i write down i'm
going to try i would my goal is to have
you understand it at three levels
the first and most important level is
the intuitive level
okay the level which you sort of
understand i call it passing the mom
test
you can go home and explain it to your
mom at thanksgiving or at the end of the
semester
okay no offense to dads just call it the
mom test
okay so basically that's the intuitive
level you really understand it way that
you could explain it
the second is graphical we were going to
do
most of our models here will develop in
a graphical framework
okay using xy graphs that we're really
weak
in economics we think delivers a lot of
shorthand power
and the third is mathematical okay the
mathematical is probably the least
important but it's the easiest to test
you on
so we're gonna need to know things
mathematically uh as well
okay um so let's start
um by considering the supply and demand
model
by using the famous example uh brought
up by adam smith
adam smith is sort of considered the
father of economics and paul sam's the
father of modern economics adam smith
the father of all economics
his 1776 book the wealth of nations
did an incredible job of actually laying
out the entire core of the economics
field
uh no math just words but kind of he
just nailed it
and um he started one of his most famous
examples was the water diamond paradox
okay he said think about water and
diamonds so start with water
nothing is more important for life than
water it's the building block of all of
life
okay even when we look for life on other
planets we start by looking for water
now think of diamonds one of the more
frivolous things you can buy
certainly irrelevant to uh leading a
successful or happy or productive life
or any life
okay yet for most of us
water's free and diamonds are super
expensive okay
how can this be adam smith asked well
the answer he posed
is that what i first described was just
demand
that is we demand lots of water we
demand fewer diamonds
but we have to match that with the
concept of supply
okay and the supply of water is almost
infinite
while the supply of diamonds maybe not
naturally maybe it's through
uh decisions of various businesses but
it's somewhat limited
okay so basically um
what what he developed is what we call
the supply and demand scissors
that you can't just think of supply or
demand in isolation you have to put them
together
if you want to explain the real world
phenomena we see like the fact that
water's cheap
and uh diamonds are expensive so let's
just talk
let's talk about an example so there's
one graph that was handed out in the
back
okay um which is let's talk about the
market for roses
okay um so
in the market for roses we have
a demand curve and a supply curve so
what we have here this is the kind of xy
graph we're going to look at all
throughout the semester
okay on the x-axis is the quantity of
roses
on the y-axis is the price of roses
the blue downward sloping line is the
demand curve
now what i'm going to do here i'm just
giving you an overview we're going to we
are going over the next six
like five or six lectures dive into
where this demand curve comes from
okay we'll go to first principles and
build it back up but for now we know
about demand curve
is it simply represents the relationship
between the price of a good and how much
people want it
therefore we assume it is downward
sloping at higher prices people want
less of the good
and we'll just we'll derive where that
comes from shortly starting next lecture
but for now i think it's pretty
intuitive that if the price of roads is
higher
people want fewer of them and that's why
it's downward sloping
okay that basically as the price of
roses goes up
people want fewer roses the yellow curve
is the supply curve now after we've
derived the demand curve we'll then go
and spend about
12 lectures to ride the supply curve
that's a bit harder but once again we'll
start from first principles and build it
up
for now you just need to know is that's
how much firms are willing to supply
given the price
so basically as the price goes up firms
want to produce more roses
okay the higher price means you make
more money so you want to produce more
of them
this is a slightly less intuitive than
demand but we'll derive it and explain
how it can be
but for now just go with the basic
intuition that if you're making
something
and you can sell in the market for a
higher price you're going to want to
make more of it
okay and that leads the upward sloping
supply curve
where the points meet is the market
equilibrium
where supply and demand meets is the
market equilibrium okay
in the that is the point where both
consumers
and producers are happy to make a
transaction
consumers are happy because they are on
their demand curve is the point
600 is the point three dollars and six
hundred roses
that is they are willing to buy six
hundred rows at three dollars
okay producers are happy because on
their supply curve is the same point
they are willing to supply 600 rows of
three dollars that is the one point
where consumers are happy and producers
are happy therefore it's the equilibrium
highly non-technical but that's the
basic intuition
okay the point at which they're both
willing to make that transaction the
point that they're both satisfied with
that transaction
is the equilibrium which in this case is
three dollars per rose and 600 roses
now this raises lots of questions where
do the curves come from
how does equilibrium get achieved um why
the heck do we give roses
these are a bunch of questions we will
um we will all
we will come to all these questions over
the next set of lectures
but the basic thing is to understand
this intuition of adam smith's supply
and demand model
okay questions about that
okay now um this model
also raises another important
distinction that will focus on the
semester and it's easy to get mixed up
so i want you to if you're ever unclear
i want you to ask me about it
and that's distinguishing between
positive
positive versus normative
analyses positive versus normative
positive analysis is the study of the
way things
are while normative analyses are this is
the study of the way things should be
okay positive analysis to study the way
things are while normative analysis
is to study the way things should be
let me give you a great example which is
uh
ebay auctions okay
auctions are a terrific example they're
like the textbook example of the
competitive market
you can see it in your head demand comes
a bunch of people going on and bidding
people who want it more bid more so you
actually get a demand curve
the higher the price the fewer people
are getting you're getting to bid
supply is how much how many units of it
are for sale on ebay
you you bid until those two meet and
then you have
a market equilibrium at that bidded
price
okay now one um
one example of an ebay auction that got
a lot of attention a number of years ago
early in the days of ebay was someone
offered their kidney for auction
they said look i got two kidneys you
only need one to live there people out
there need a kidney
i'm putting my kidney on ebay for
auction um
and what happened bidding went nuts it
started at 25 000
it climbed to 5 million before the
auction was shut down and ebay decided
they wouldn't
allow you to sell your body on ebay
bodily parts on ebay okay
so this raises two questions
the first is the positive question why
did the price go so high
so what's the answer to that what's the
answer to the positive question
okay let's look good but let's let's
raise hands and
give ants that's part of it yeah
supply high demand demand is incredibly
high because i die without it
supply is low because like not a lot of
us are willing to sell their kitties on
ebay
okay so low supply high demand led to a
high price
adam smith at work that's the positive
analysis
okay but this raises the north but then
there's the normative question
which is should you be allowed to sell
your kidneys on ebay
that's the normative question the
positive question is what happens if you
do
the normative question is should you now
the standard economics answer to start
would be
of course you should we're in a world
where
thousands of people die every year
because there's a waiting list for a
kidney transplant
okay and these are people who would
happily pay a lot of money to stay alive
i presume
okay meanwhile there's
hundreds of millions of people walking
around with two kidneys
who only need one and many of these
people
are poor and lives could be changed by
being paid a million dollars for their
kidney
and might be happy to take the risk that
their other that one kidney will be fine
as it is for most everyone for most of
their life
in return for having the life-changing
payment from a stranger
so economists say look here's a
transaction to make both parties better
off
the person who gets the kidney gets to
stay alive and they're what they are
willing to pay a huge amount for that
the person who sells the kidney in most
probability is
fine because almost all of us can make
it through life fine with one kidney
and get a life-changing amount of money
that could allow them to pursue their
dreams in various ways
okay so that's the standard argument
would be
yeah you should be able to sell your
kidneys on ebay
okay so the question is why not
why would we want to stop this
transaction what are the counter
arguments
to that let's raise our rates yeah
like i i think maybe the issue was like
because it was ebay there's like no way
to regulate it
or like you don't like necessarily know
like people could be like selling fake
kidneys per se
right so the first type of problem comes
out of the category we call
market failures
market failures are reasons why the
market doesn't work in the wonderful way
economists like to think it should
so for example this answer puts up that
could be the problem
of um fraud
okay people might not be able to tell
if they're getting a legit kidney or not
okay
there could be the example of imperfect
information
do you know what the odds are that you
can spend the rest of your life with
only one kidney
i don't either okay we ought to know
that
before we start selling our kidneys okay
there could be a perfect information
okay these are the kinds of this is one
type of problem which is the market
maybe the market may fail
like okay current system also helps
people who are
poor and have failed kidney um
and which would be which are people to
be completely screwed underwater
the set a second problem is what we call
equity
or fairness
equity or fairness which is
we would end up with a world where only
rich people would get kidneys
okay currently there's a bunch of
voluntary donors and people who are in
accidents who have kidneys left over
okay and those go to a people on the
base of where they are in a waiting list
actually a prioritized waiting list it's
kind of a cool
one of my colleagues nikhil agarwal if
you think about
i'll talk a lot this semester about the
imperialistic view of economics all the
cool things we can study
so he actually uses economic models to
study the optimal way to allocate organs
to individuals right now it's just done
based on a waiting list
but but it may be that someone further
down the waiting list needs it more than
so and higher up the waiting list
because they're more critical or
whatever so there's various
optimum ways to allocate but certainly
although it allocate wouldn't be the
rich guy gets it first
that would be unlikely to be what
society would necessarily want
so there's an equity concern with that
what else
what other sorts yeah really
since you know you can make money off of
selling kidneys and you take advantage
of people
and it's very bad black market for
kidneys
right so there's sort of a third it's
related to fraud but there's sort of a
third class of failures
that gets into the question about mis
behavioral economics we talked that was
raised earlier
which we could just call so failing
behavioral
it's called behavioral economics for one
of a better term which is essentially
people don't always make decisions in
the perfectly rational logical way we
will model them as doing so this
semester
people make mistakes that's a word we
hate using economics we hate saying
mistakes ooh boo
mistakes nobody makes mistakes we're all
perfect little economic beings but we
know that's not true
increasingly over the past several
decades economists have started
incorporating insights from psychology
into our models to not just say people
make mistakes that's a lackadaisical but
to rigorously model the nature of those
mistakes
and understand how mistakes can actually
happen
due to virus cognitive biases and other
things in this world you can imagine
people could
make mistakes they could be they could
not really sit down and quite understand
what they're doing
and they could have selling their kidney
when it's really not in their own
long-term interest
yeah example be like if there's like a
family that's like an extreme poverty
like
even though they only have one kidney
they might sell the other one just to
give them money for the family per se
well i mean in subsets that would be
once again
in a if we took this factor out we took
if we took
if we took if the market worked well
there's no behavioral effects we'd say
well you know what that's their decision
you know if they otherwise they starve
who are you to say
okay but once you choose this say well
wait a second maybe they're not
evaluating the trade-offs correctly
even if there's no fraud even if there's
perfect information they may not know
how to process that information
correctly
okay but that is not standard economics
that's not what we'll spend a lot of
time in the semester but it's obviously
realistic
okay so those are a bunch of good
comments great comments
and that yeah they're also an inelastic
demand
such that people will always need
kidneys that won't turn out to be a pro
that doesn't turn out to be a problem
okay we'll come back that's a great
comeback though we talk about the shape
and demand curves
if you want to return to that question a
few lectures but that doesn't actually
cause a problem
it's just that's more of a positive
thing about why the price is so high but
it's not a normative issue about whether
you should allow it or not
okay so basically these are exactly
this isn't to me honestly i spend my
life thinking a lot about these things i
think these are really interesting
issues
but you can't get to the nordic issues
without the positive analysis
usually the positive analysis to
understand the economic framework
before you start jumping you're drawing
conclusions that's no fun we all want to
jump to draw conclusions
saying this should happen it shouldn't
happen you can't do that we have to be
disciplined
we have to start with the fundamental
economic framework
okay and basically the bottom line you
know i said i'll teach this course with
a policy bent
but you have to recognize that economics
at its core is a right-wing science
economics at its core is all about how
the market knows best
okay and that basically governments only
mess things up
that's sort of the basic a lot of what
we'll learn this semester as semester
goes on and we'll talk about what's
wrong with that view
and how governments can improve things
indeed i teach a whole course about the
proper role of government
economy but the standard of economics is
the market knows best
okay and that leads us to the last thing
i want to talk about
which is basically how freely should an
economy function let's step back to the
giant picture
let's step back from a market for roses
to the entire economy
how freely should a market should an
economy function
we have what's known as a capitalistic
economy
in a capitalistic economy firms that
individuals decide what to produce and
consume
may be subject to some rules of the road
set by the government there's some
minimal rules of the road
to try to avoid fraud or misinformation
but otherwise we let the dice roll
firms and consumers decide sort of what
to uh
what to do now this has led to
tremendous growth
okay america was not a wealthy nation it
was not very wealthy nation
a hundred years ago 150 years ago it's
led to tremendous growth where we are
now
the most powerful still the most
powerful and wealthiest nation in the
world
okay largely driven by the
capitalist nation capitalistic nature of
our economy
on the other hand we are a nation with
tremendous inequality
we are by far the most unequal major
nation in the world okay
the top one percent of americans has a
much higher share of our income
than in any other large country in the
world any other large developed country
in the world
the bottom 99 has less of our income
corresponding than anywhere else so it's
led to major inequality
and it's led to other problems it turns
out that the government can
appropriately set the rules the road to
avoid things like fraud
as we saw with enron if you remember
back to that or a lot of what happened
during the financial meltdown
it turns out it's hard to get people
perfect information etc
so we've seen the problems we've grown
very wealthy as a nation
but we've introduced a whole set of
problems through the system
now the other extreme is what's called
the command economy
rather than a capitalist economy is
what's called a command economy
okay in this case the government makes
all the production and consumption
decisions the government needs to set
the rules the road the government
owns the road the government says we're
going to produce this many
cars this year okay and people
can get them in some way it could be a
lottery could be waiting in line however
we decide to allocate them
we're not going to let the market
allocate them we the government will
allocate them well okay how many get
produced
and who gets them okay and this was the
model the soviet union that i grew up
with
okay this was the pre-1989 soviet union
okay the government decided how many
shirts cars cds every i mean it's sort
of bizarre to think about literally
everything
the government decided how much to
produce and by and large the government
decided who got it
partly through corruption that is the
party p the party members
party leaders got it first and often
just through waiting in line
for the remaining application now in
theory
this ensured equity by making sure that
everybody is shot at things
in practice it didn't work well at all
and actually was what dragged down
the collapse of the old soviet economy
was that the command model
simply doesn't work partly there's just
too many opportunities for corruption
when the government controls everything
that means there's no checks and
balances
on the the the the opportunity for
enormous corruption
the capitalist economy puts some natural
checks and balances on that
and partly because it turns out that
it's hard to control human nature
and adam smith had it right adam smith
talks about the invisible hand
of the capitalist economy the invisible
hand is
basically the notion that the capitalist
economy will manage distribute things
roughly
in proportion what people want okay and
that's
where peak folks want to be they folks
who want a certain kind of car are going
to want to get to that kind of car
and the government has it wrong they're
going to get upset and it's going to
lead to a less functional economy
okay so basically um
adam smith's view is that the invisible
hand view is that consumers
and firms serving their own best
interest
will do what is best for society okay so
the fundamental core of the capitalistic
view
is the consumers and firms serving their
own best interests
will do what ends up being best for
society and that's essentially the model
we'll learn to start in this course
yeah um in that definition are we
defining the best for society as you're
like like everybody has the most money
or like everyone has the best health or
the best and from living like
what is the best great great question
we're going to spend a lot of the
semester talking about that
for now we're going to find best for
society as the most
stuff gets produced and consumed okay
that's how we're going to find it
obviously you've raised a set of issues
about what about pollution what about
health
etc we're going to come to those but for
the first
two thirds of the course best for
society means
what we're going to call maximum surplus
which is
the most stuff gets produced that people
value okay
so that's that's how we're going to do
it and in his view the visual hand does
that
and by and large by and large it's a
very helpful framework
to turn to okay however at least the
outcomes that
can lead to outcomes that are not very
fair so the way we're going to proceed
in this course
is we're going to start by talking about
how adam smith's magic works
how does the magic happen how does
individuals and firms act in their own
self-interest
without caring about anybody else end up
yielding
the largest si possible the the largest
possible productive economy
okay how does that happen okay and we're
going to talk about that
we'll start with demand which is how do
consumers decide what they want
given their resources we'll talk about
the principle of utility maximization
the idea that i have utility function
that i can math mathematically write
down
what i want i'll have a budget
constraint which is the resource i have
and the ones do constrained optimization
we'll say give them what i want and the
resource i have
what decisions do i make boom we get the
demand curve then we'll turn to supply
and we'll talk about how do firms decide
what to produce
that's much more complicated because
firms have to decide what inputs to use
and what outputs to produce and we'll
talk about how firms operate
can operate in very different markets
there's a competitive market that
smith envisioned but that doesn't always
work sometimes we get monopoly markets
okay where one firm dominates and you
can actually end up outcomes which
aren't the best possible outcome even
with the invisible hand
okay so we'll talk about different kinds
of markets then we'll put it together to
get market equilibrium
and talk about sort of smith's
principles and then from there we'll
talk about how it
breaks down in reality different change
in reality how there are various market
failures
that can get in the way why we have to
care about equity and what implications
that has
about behavioral economics about a set
of other factors
okay so that's basically how we're going
to proceed uh this semester
as i said the lectures are important but
the rest stations are as well
once we're sort of in steady state the
rest station is about half
uh working half new material and half
working through problems
to help you prepare for the next problem
set so the problem sets are going to
work
is the problem set that's assigned will
cover material that's taught
up to that date so for example problem
set one is to be assigned next friday
that will cover everything you've
learned up through next wednesday
okay therefore in section on next friday
we'll do a practice problem
which will help which you should
understand because we'll cover things
we've taught in class
and he'll prepare you for the problem
set and we'll do that every week
that about half the sections the other
half the section will be new material
okay this friday the section friday is
all new material
we're doing fridays cover the
mathematics i don't like doing math
i always get it wrong okay so i leave
math for the tas who are smarter than i
am
okay so this friday we're doing the
mathematics of supply and demand
and how you take the intuition here and
the simple graphics and actually turn it
into
mathematical representations which is
what you need for the problem sets
that this friday then we'll come back on
monday and start talking about
uh what's underneath the demand curve
all right any other questions
okay i'll see you on monday